My oncologist said that my cancer could also change from horrible and positive negative,
trying to get me to do a biopsy again. I would totally agree with you. Matter of fact,
I can't tell you how many people, how many women that will start with us, so they have
grant, they have hormone negative, so they have triple negative breast cancer. And we test that
just in our cheek, so I'm testing that they do well with a dim or something like that.
So I don't believe all those pathology reports personally. So regardless of whether your cancer
switches to horrible negative or horrible positive, that would just be, I think your oncologist is
just concerned that they want to switch the therapy, so they want to do change a drug.
So if you're on a drug slash chemotherapy with your oncologist, that's based upon
you be grand positive or grand negative, then maybe testing is in order for them. But we've had
we've had patients too with multiple breast lesions and biopsy, different breast lesions,
and one comes back, grand, or horrible positive, and one comes back, or no negative. So
so I don't always trust those pathology reports. But if you're not doing,
you know, if you're not currently doing chemo, or you don't plan on doing chemo, or you're not
doing any medication, what does it make a difference to them, whether you're horrible positive or negative?
So that would be my concern.